what's up you little hamster wranglin
scoliosis crabapple weeders you guys
ready huh
you ready to play a little bit of junk
bump with Daddy you ready for some
powdered sugar up in your bud
nya beta we got one of the oldest
wiggers in the game coming in studio we
got a wonderful episode we get some
first-time callers talking about crotch
touch their first experience and it's
the Mother's Day aftermath so thank you
for joining me welcome to this past
weekend this past weekend
[Music]
who
you're that
[Applause]
beautiful music huh that is the dragon
challenge by epidemic sound makes me
feel like a like a queen is just passed
by you know like oh her majesty you know
like a beautiful Queen is just gonna buy
on a boat like a nice boat made out of
pearl or something like that or
something that looks like pearl that
would float you know oh there's a queen
there's the queen I say that because
Mother's Day Mother's Day has come and
gone and everybody's uh you know
hopefully gotten to spend some time with
her mother talked to him had a nice
conversation or listened to him I find
as I get older it's about just listening
to my mother you know I just want to
make sure that uh that she's okay and
that she's trying you know she's not
worrying I think those are things that
start to help me the most spoke to my
mother today I sent her some flowers
actually from bloom that you might have
heard of we'd been advertising for them
I sent some flowers to her from there
and she has a husband who has
Alzheimer's and so he don't do much he
was in the war he was in a maybe a
couple Wars I think maybe I want to say
him possibly the Korean War he's got
some issues with some Asians I do know
that doesn't make him a bad person they
had issues with him as well I'm sure
during the war so but he don't do much
he liked to put on mittens or gloves and
he likes to take him off so that's one
of his hobbies these days a couple times
he would break out of the house and go
get himself a little law can of liquor
or can of beer and he would have that
somewhere being sneaky and my mother
would have to go find him so that's kind
of what he's up to
you know and he have Alzheimer's so it
was nice to speak to my mother and just
make sure she was okay she had some she
enjoyed her flowers and the flowers came
with some caramels different you know
fancy brown candies
nice ones the melting your mouth and
make you feel you know make it face make
your whole mouth feel kind of almost
naughty a little bit salty and sweet and
kind of just nasty a little but also
good and beautiful so she enjoyed those
I'm pretty sure and we had a nice time
man you know I'm at the age now where I
can it's not about holding any grudges
against my mother
it's about finding solutions if I do
have issues we're more and more a little
bit able to talk about things and and
it's just about kind of just let her
know that I love her you know you know I
feel like when I think about it and I'm
sorry welcome to this past weekend man
I'm just talking out of the blue out
here you know I want to thank you guys
for joining me I hope your mother's days
were beautiful I hope I saw a lot of
pictures on Instagram on people's
mothers I liked as many as I could and I
you know it was uh but I spoke to my mom
and and I just want her to be happy
that's all I want you know when I was
young I thought I was a daddy's boy you
know we're a dad's boy whatever it's
called a caring member daddy's boy
sounds almost like you know somebody
that's um being hired is like a male
escort or something maybe out in
Scottsdale or in Palm Springs so I'm not
bad I just thought I was my dad wasn't
around so I thought I was a father you
know uh I just wanted to be that you
know cuz when you when you're young you
want to be whatever you're not kind of
you know you want to be the you know you
just you want to raise hell you want to
cause ruckus so that's how I thought I
was a daddy's boy
but I wasn't man as I get older I
realize that I'm just you notice with my
mother to be happy and I just you know
I'm like my mother in a lot of ways some
good and some bad but but I'm more of a
mama's boy and took me a long time to
realize that but now I'm realizing it
now but yet at a certain point you can
hold grudges him I'm still holding
grudges against my mother I'm 37 years
old and something's wrong then it's my
issue it's not our issue anymore it's my
issue so I have to figure out what's
going on if I am come to terms with it
and get out of it because life is short
and our lives are short and and I wonder
I was home mother to be happy you know
when I think about it we had a little
bit of a tough spell over over growing
up and I was pretty blessed man I found
a bunch of different mothers that took
me in and into their families and into
their homes and made me feel like a like
a just like a regular kid you know and
loved me and and helped me out as much
as possible you know I got emancipated
at 14 and I spent time living with
friends and families and I've just been
eternally when I really think about it
blessed by the by the grace that people
showed me I mean I have been shown more
joy than more Grace and more just I've
just I've been helped I've been helped
so it's amazing to me that a mother that
they can extend beyond their own
children when they have a lot of those
qualities and it's just it's it's pretty
fascinating and and but these days you
know I talked to my mother and I just
wanted to be happy you know and she
sometimes she just talks and talks and I
don't know what she's talking about now
I just try to listen and be a quiet
listener try to be supportive but she
got some tulips that's what I said I
hope she enjoyed them i'ma jump off that
conversation right now or actually I
guess when I think about my mother even
more you know I didn't always treat my
mother very good that's one thing I
realized as I get older I wasn't a good
son you know I have some
responsibilities as a son you know I've
talked about this before but you know I
rejected my mother a lot of times you
know I wasn't like a proud son a lot of
times I was you know I was just
uncomfortable and I was just selfish and
I know I was a child and
a right to be selfish as a child because
you have to have your needs met when
you're a young child but as you get
older you you can you can just be being
selfish you know if all you're concerned
about is getting your needs met then at
a certain point there's a lot of
selfishness there and and and I and I
was at a lot of times and I rejected my
mother you know because we didn't have
any money sometimes and you know I
reject her maybe because she didn't my
mother was a hard worker still is and
she didn't take care of herself that
much so she didn't care about beauty she
didn't care about you know looking
fancier putting on makeup or anything
but that made me feel you know like I
like she just didn't care about putting
on airs for anyone she was very real
woman and at the time when I was young I
just I guess I wanted her to put on airs
I wanted you know that idea of a mom
that you see like on the televisions you
know on leave it to beavers and stuff
like that different shows you know
regular shows Roseanne but more of a
sustained Roseanne so you know I
rejected my mother a lot and I feel bad
about some of those things but I'm old
you know but but now's one of the
blessings of so having my mom and I'm
able to discuss those things with her
and get into them and um you know it's
never too late to apologize it doesn't
be a special phone call that you make to
your mom doesn't have to be on Mother's
Day it can be on any Monday like today
if you got something to say just get it
out of your heart and get it out of your
soul and get it into your mother's ears
you know there's no place better for our
sons concerns I don't think than their
mother's ears even if she's not going to
give you the response you want I think
there's just something about a son or a
daughter saying something to their
mother you know and just putting it on
them that that is uh innately comforting
to us and I'll put a lot of pressure on
my mom growing up you know it was just
her and when you're when you're a child
like that you know and it's just your
mother you naturally look to your mother
for
for whatever your father supposed to
give you as well and so it can give you
a it can put you know ridiculous on
unachievable desires and expectations on
your mother because you are looking for
a complete circle of parenting and
there's no way your mother can give it
all to you because she can't be a man
she can't be you know two parents so
there's also so I have a lot of you know
I'll probably have some resentments or
you know some amends to make in that
category to once I figure out what
expectations I put on my mother that I
probably was supposed to put on a father
but they weren't there because that's
not my mother's responsibility you know
there's that's my father's
responsibility he wasn't around but
anyway I'm not trying to bring everybody
down I started [ __ ] off bad what the
[ __ ] do I don't know I don't know man we
got a good episode dude I got the oldest
Wigga in the game coming in mr. Roger
rod I've been a fan of this man for a
long time and I've seen him here and
there and you guys gonna be excited we
got some great calls that came in from
some from some listeners I wanted to a
special episode this week I think
hopefully just about I think it's going
to be about manhood and what that means
we've had a lot of a lot of a lot of
calls about it and thank you so much for
calling and hitting the hotline that
number is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three
we got people calling in about the first
time they touch some crotch and I'm
sharing those experiences and I'm going
to I mean I know it's a weird thing on a
mother's mother's after days special to
get into that but we're going to get
into that some of those crotch calls and
take some Krotz callers so want to be a
balla
crotch Carla so is fascinated by that I
think because crunching crunching tots
boy touching crotch when you're young it
just I mean it is like a dam I mean it's
like somebody just it's like the first
time you ever see one of those babies
they could hear for the
first time on those videos it's like dis
magic baby they put you know they put
headphones on this magic baby and you
know baby could see for the first time
baby gets retinas repaired for the first
time when I see that that's what it is
like I am an it is anyway the first time
you down there touching some will say
cooter you know to keep things
comfortable here on this Mother's Day
special will say cooter the first time
you see in some cooter you really are
touching some it's like that first time
it's like it's just like one of those
videos on Facebook where you know like
um dog here's its owner you know dog
here's its owner for the first time dog
sees its cousin for the first time you
know it's like one of those you know
it's one of those man it's that magical
moment where it's like this area that
you can and there's so much heat that's
what I remember about that crotch he
brought it was I mean god it was like
somebody had just put a furnace inside
of you know a woman's pants I mean it
was just like you ever get those mitten
packets that keep your hands warm if you
do skiing or you do outdoor work in the
in the Kodiak or in the cold weather you
know or if you know if your freezer
doesn't have a door your refrigerator
doesn't have a door and you get your
kitchen gets really cold because they
don't have it uh ways to close them up
and you have to use those freezer
packets you know and I said I'm sure
that's probably erroneous a lot of
people don't have that I had a friend
who didn't have any of any freezer door
refrigerator door someone had stolen the
doors to their appliance many of their
appliances actually and and so the cold
would always be coming out and so they'd
have to wear extra shirts and stuff but
you have this they have these hand
warmers you can get and man it was like
the first time you put your hand down by
a girl's crotch that's kind of what
occurred I felt like well we're going to
get into some of those some of those
calls
and we're going to get to our guests
we're going to get to it I'm tell you
what else it had this past weekend not
much man you know to be honest with you
I had I probably had like I think 16
comedy sets at the different clubs hung
out with Howie Mandel for a little bit
it was nice actually how he's always
been really nice to me he's a charming
man
and we had a good time I got to see him
and his wife she's a lovely lady we had
a nice time man how he's funny and he's
good he's got a great heart
you ever see celebrities on TV you don't
know what some of them are like that's
fine but you can know this about Howie
Mandel he may seem bizarre you know and
maybe his humor is fewer isn't for you
that's not to be judged I mean that you
can judge it that's fun but but don't
but don't doubt that he's a nice man
he's a very nice man he's just a good
guy what else happened dude
I felt better I appreciate it I got a
lot of calls from from people this week
seeing how I was feeling and I feel a
little bit better some of that was as
being off the road and being able to be
at home and enjoy and just enjoy my
environment man my plants were dying I
got two plants and they were dying so it
was just felt a little bit better I took
a walk today so I'm gonna drop these
dates on you guys right now and then
we're going to get into our guest he's
going to be here in studio and then we
need some calls man these are some of
our favorite calls I'm really really
excited about this next weekend the 25th
or 28th I'll be at Tampa at the side
splitters comedy club and then I'll be
in Pittsburgh June 1st through June 4th
okay and then I will be at Gotham in New
York City June 23rd through June 24th
and New York City in New York they call
it the same thing to piss you off right
there and then I'm in Wyoming Illinois
and that's about a an hour from the Quad
Cities in Iowa it's a small small town
at the Paramount Theater and those
tickets are available on Theo von comm I
also have a new album that came out it's
a my early
now if you picked up an album at my show
it might be the same material so I'm
just letting you know that if you want
to check the material before you
purchase it but it's a musket fire the
early years of satire and that's
available now on iTunes it's a lot of
the stuff from the Netflix special so
it's not material that is similar it's
not the same material from the Netflix
vessel but it's a similar material and
it's uh it's on sale now
it'll be where else I'll be at the
improv in Orlando I think we move those
dates to July 13 through 16 also you can
grab 30 pound bag of hamster bones which
is still on sale and Theo von comm slash
store is where you can get most things
t-shirts as well all right
we got a guest in I'm excited for him
it's late here guys honestly it's 1:00
a.m. here on Pacific Standard Coast time
coastal time this past weekend all right
happy to have him here today man thank
you so much for joining me what I want
to say one of the realists and oldest
wiggers in the game mr. Roger rod so
Roger I gotta ask are you black or white
I would have to say I'm white on the
outside and multi-coloured inside okay
multicolor and what colors were gonna
see in there for to crack you open it
cracked me over and I probably bleed red
but a lot of me still identifies as a
black a lot I do I don't think I'm black
I don't try to act like but I very much
appreciate that culture it parts of it I
don't like but the major portion of it
what I love most about it is the
indomitable spirit they refuse to be
unhappy no matter how many times or ways
they get [ __ ] culturally they always
see the upside
you know it's interesting because I just
feel like I'm some of them like do black
people even feel bad like do they even
feel sad you know like because my keys
are always pretty upbeat or level and
I'll sometimes I've and maybe I've
mistook in it as that black people just
do they not
have those feelings I would say without
even knowing what the statistics are but
if you looked at them they probably got
the lowest suicide rate I have to think
so they always find a reason to keep
trying keep fighting something to be
happy about why I'm finna see an upside
with most positive culture I remember
when I first started playing black clubs
it was a really low point in my life I'd
gone through a bad romance i was more
poverty-stricken that it ever been my
career didn't seem to be going anywhere
and I'm playing a black clubs and I'm in
these really low low low income
neighborhoods and I'm being as kind as I
can and seeing comics that I knew were
limiting cars and living in very poor
conditions and they would get on stage
and say something like I walk out today
the Sun hit my face is a beautiful thing
to be alive and the thing what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me that if this guy can
see life that way where did I go wrong
what's so bad about my life Wow real
positivity yeah
and you play football with him and you
really get it they never go to your
brothers
and the other thing I noticed on the
football scene is that you would get on
these 14-hour bus drives we sometimes
had to take and the white guys would all
be sitting around bored shitless maybe
reading a book but most the time just
staring at the front seat and the blacks
are in back playing dominoes and playing
spades and cars yucking it up laughing
up high five and they always were
[ __ ] having more fun than we were and
I started hanging around with them yeah
yeah why do black people have more fun
than I do because I yeah like I like the
most fun sometimes white people it
seemed like like white people would be
like you know like you know like I'm
having a good time you know but like
black people will really like you know
if they're having a good time and they
usually are they can get a big kick out
of a very small thing yeah and that's
what's really funny culturally is some
of the times something that you and I
would say to each other if we were just
kind of exchanging insults in a friendly
way that it wouldn't be anything
particularly funny but it's something
their culture has never heard it like I
called this guy you snot-nosed little
[ __ ] and that just killed him you
snot-nosed little [ __ ] just they'd
never heard a man call another man a
snot-nosed little [ __ ] and but now some
of the names that they come up with it
you and I never heard it
on the floor so we're the [ __ ] did you
put that combination of words together
why is it that I feel like a lot of the
younger black comics now couldn't make
it in a black room younger black comics
you mean such as the ones you see in a
mainstream club yeah
because they've geared their act towards
a white audience
they've geared their act to cross over
to a wide audience and done material
that is very different from the culture
that they come from right most of the
time or they're suburb blacks that are
more comfortable in the white culture
because they're not familiar with the
hood right that's often the case as well
a suburb black has almost as much
disconnect to the black culture as you
and I do why is it hard even like I mean
I grew up in like a white hood you know
I mean it was you know we're right on we
shared you know we're right next to the
poor black neighborhood was a poor white
neighborhood I mean there wasn't we all
wrote the same school buses together why
is it that it's hard to let go of the
hood for people do you feel like even if
they transcend class or environment why
does like the hood like stick to you
you know I'm talking about it all I
surely do and it is a phenomenon that's
very difficult for us to understand it's
something that I think there's a part of
it that they like the idea that this is
something I rose up from and the friends
that I have left behind are now my
entourage and my fan club and the people
that I know that I can trust to have the
most connection towards like biggie when
he was at his apex a lot of times he
said he found himself daydreaming about
what was going on in the hood and here's
a guy living in penthouse private jet
level wealth and I was wondering what
are the home he's doing on the streets
yeah and that's just something that is a
very difficult thing to disconnect from
yeah and I guess because maybe life so
real out there like you know I felt like
even in our neighborhood life was very
real for us because we all spend time
together outdoors you know like there
wasn't anything going on in doors except
like fighting you know the air we
couldn't run the air conditioner so it
was like it wasn't even comfortable to
be indoors so everybody was outdoors and
that's where
you know you just got acclimated in your
environment you really in your
environment right you know you didn't
just meet up for like playdates like
kids do now or eggs off like that I mean
we spent our lives outdoors and we go
yeah that's one thing you don't see that
much of anymore particularly in white
culture yeah I mean could you imagine
probably in the home you grew up in and
on a nice bright sunshiny day you're
sitting on the couch playing with your
xbox my mom and dad what I said get the
[ __ ] outside and go play yeah you're not
sitting around on that thing all day
yeah yeah no yeah I would have been or
given us a set amount of time but then
it's time to go then it's time to go
exactly yeah you guys need to get
outside and didn't even really keep tabs
I think now everybody's just scared of
like kidnappers you know like I was
talking about and and in PDF files of
attacking children you know and stuff
like that but you cannot even enjoy
years of playing outside because it may
be one PDF file that seems intense to me
you know in it and it really is a sad
thing that we have come to that such as
now we're living in a culture that is
swung once again with that pendulum too
far in one direction where you'll see a
parent smack their kid in the ass in the
grocery market and then 15 minutes later
Child Protective Services at their front
door and they're their child abusers
that was not part of our lives growing
up now and the kind of thing about
walking to and from school at the age of
say six years old a six-year-old kid
walking to and from school by himself
right now the police are going to show
up yeah and they're probably going to
harass the parents there's some kind of
child endangerment Christ we did it all
the time that was part of it now I know
sometimes my tone of voice will change
when I'm around black people you know
for uncertain black people some other
people that won't and maybe that's just
nature of just acclimating to an
environment what do you think about that
because I know this happens a lot with
white people and black people as long as
it's not overdone if it's something that
I look at it that I get a little jargony
because when I'm around Latinos I speak
a little bit of Spanish yeah I'll even
pull a Latino accent a Mexican accent I
when I'm around when anyone that you run
if you around a bunch of blue bloods
you're going to change your whole style
yeah you put all you have to really do
to change your entire personality is put
on a [ __ ] suit sometime and walk out
the door and immediately have a
different attitude yeah and a whole
different demeanor about you maybe for
like [ __ ]
right a job yeah we're all things to all
people there's nothing wrong with it as
long as you don't overdo it yeah that's
the urban update right there from the
white side the white guy yes was a
bridge to Tara the bit the bridge to
Blackaby Thea and which you are a little
bit for us man you know because you've
been out there you're learning man
learning is the best way to put it part
of the culture absolutely not I always
say the same thing to the newer white
comics when they come into the club this
is what you need to remember act like
you're a guest in somebody's home
because you are because when these black
comics go to the mainstream clubs they
get treated like [ __ ] so don't act like
you have some entitlement to be on the
stage act like you're a guest in
someone's home in Tennessee I think it's
a great thing to remember for almost no
matter where we are you know but
especially um yeah culturally you know
we stop to remember that there's you
know even though we're all Americans
that there's a lot of like there's a lot
of cultural differences you know
gigantic gigantic and all and and to say
the other thing is that we all don't we
all we people say the term that we're
all racist I don't believe in that
because again I've said for the
umpteenth time there's one race the
human race yeah but I think we all are
guilty of prejudice those of us that are
going to be honest prejudice the root of
which is prejudge we all see somebody of
a different culture and prejudge them in
some way or another consciously or
unconsciously for example you're on a
plane somebody walks in with the turban
what do you think the turban of what a
meaning that they walk in with they
walking with a burka they walk in well
ahead are you yeah you're walking with
something I don't what I'm thinking of
yeah but you see somebody that's clearly
from the Middle East what's the first
thing you think it oh yeah they're
probably hiding jewels or something or
they're they got a bomb or sky it's [ __ ]
just gonna hijack them yeah the razor
blade or who knows what but you're not
thinking and I certainly have pre
judging's towards people that aren't
necessarily non-white skin I prejudge
the Russian culture oh yeah quite a bit
I do that now oh yeah I do everyone a
stereotype everyone for sure are
stereotype I'm a stereotype this time I
be a stenographer you know I mean I I do
and some of those stereotypes are good
and accurate give you healthy ways to
approach people but
yeah when you I guess going to a place a
judgement sometimes can be a you know it
can be dangerous because you might not
get you you might not get the full
opportunity out of an opportunity
what if there's judgement it'll it'll
make you a better person just like I
think we've discussed anything I won't
say anything out of school but we're at
least both familiar with 12-step groups
yeah and the first chance anybody has to
ever beat an addiction is they must be
able to look to a crowd and say hi my
name is blank I am an alcoholic yeah and
once you recognize hi my name is Roger
and I have prejudice towards other
people and that's your first chance to
give yourself at least a fighting
opportunity to overcome it and recognize
when you're doing it yeah and the first
thing that I can think of is I add a
Corvette back in jazz with some 98 at a
Corvette that literally caught fire with
me inside of it in a pouring down rain
storm I barely got to the freeway exit
barely got out of the car alive with the
thing almost in bursting flames and
pouring down rain it was in the middle
of Oakland I ran two blocks and I look
like a wet soaked rat into this liquor
store I didn't have a dime in my pocket
everything was still in the car and two
middle-eastern guys that I would have
been writing jokes about treated me like
I was a long looking here have a cup of
coffee use our foam blanket don't worry
my friend you can always buy another car
you're here it's live and I felt like a
piece of [ __ ] because of the way I often
speak about that culture well so you
know we all have to keep our minds open
and recognize yeah I've got this in me
yes yeah you never know when you're
gonna need someone of another culture
you know I don't even need anyone else
you never know when you can need to have
a better opinion of yourself yeah it's a
good way to look at it yeah that's a
great way to look at it well that's it
Roger odd I appreciate you coming in and
people can find you if they want to
support the tour blue lives matter blue
lives matter Comedy Tour
Namba tour yes and Escom and at Roger
rod on Twitter and an Instagram and
Facebook same thing and ROG ER ro d ROG
ER ro D D all one word yeah
you guys check them out the oldest
wigger in the game here with us today
and one of my favorite comedians to
watch man did I appreciate what you do
man as I really do feel like you know
you're helping people realize that that
we can learn man you know well as much
as I appreciate you for having me on the
show you're a very accomplished
certainly a lot further along in this
game than I am for you to have brought
me on board is a big honor well I hope
I'm able to sit there one day and be
able to rehash so many good stories and
that's such a good attitude about my
career and just about myself and and
about what's going on and to be able to
inspire other people to UM you know
think they don't have to think
differently but at least in power I'm
gonna start by thinking you know I think
you do that already thanks man I
appreciate it appreciate you all right
we'll be right back we're gonna get some
we need some of you guys's questions we
got some great ones on this Mother's Day
episode this past weekend this past
weekend all right let's get to some
callers guys I'm so thankful for the
calls just the questions I'm gonna try
to do another episode this week for your
Wednesday or Thursday it's just a lot
but i'ma try and it's just a lot because
you know I got to pay somebody to edit
it and I got a just to piece it together
there's just a lot of stuff that goes
into it I've got a rent studio if I need
the studio so there's a lot of little
things that go into it but I'm
overwhelmed with the amount of calls and
questions and inquiries and um and just
you I just want to say you're welcome a
lot of people have said thank you I
don't feel like I'm doing I don't feel
like I'm doing anything I feel like I'm
kind of a conduit of of just trying to
make an effort you know like I think a
lot of my life I feel like I I don't
know if I felt like I haven't been a
good person but it's like I've just
thought about myself and you know I
don't want to be that way always you
know sometimes selfishness is a it's a
disease a little bit
you know because it's sometimes you're
selfish you know I think I was selfish
growing up because I was just worried
that if I didn't think about myself that
nobody was going to be and I may have
said this before but it's just kind of
resonating with you right now like I
think I was you know I was selfish
because I was worried I was afraid like
if I don't think about me then nobody is
going to be thinking about me in the
world and when you're a kid that's a
scary
that's a scariest thing in the world you
know to think that no one's gonna be
thinking about you I just you know I
don't know anything more hurtful to a
child probably than to feel then the
feel that no one is going to be thinking
about them that they're unthought-of and
so I think I definitely develop some
selfishness there as a child you know I
was just worried that if I wasn't
thinking about me that no one was and
then you get addicted to that you just
get used to it it becomes a habit I have
to think about me you know as a child
but then as an adult you're just still
stranded with this habit that's not
serving you anymore and to get out of
that I have to do things for other
people
and I'm still learning that and I got to
try harder
but it is nice to know that some of you
guys think that this podcast is helping
to do that because it makes me feel a
little less selfish or it makes you feel
like I'm battling that leftover bad
habit of just being self-serving you
know one especially I live in a
self-serving City you know I have a
self-serving job I feel like people say
my job brings laughter to people but you
know it's hard not to feel like like
that it's just for me sometimes or I
don't know but but I love you and I
appreciate the calls and uh and I'm
grateful man there's so many nice
messages and stuff I wish I could play
every one for you and I'm gonna try to
slowly incorporate in my save them all
so when they'll fit in they'll fit in
but but let's get some calls we do have
some female listeners
there and they're growing our female
listeners population is growing and I'm
excited about that and we had a we had
some callers calling about the first
time they touched a little bit of crotch
and when you touch crotch as a child you
know that's that is it's like I mean I
can't it's like it's just like somebody
have you ever see have like a friend you
know you ever have to see those mitten
packets that keep your hands warm it's
like a special packet that you buy that
you put into a mitten or a if you have a
bag or something put your hands in a bag
but it's cold in the bag they got these
little heat warmer packet so you can
break kind of or bend and it cracked
something inside of them and it makes
heat free heat small small amount of
heat and people put those in their
mittens or their socks or whatever and
those things warm they just just intense
warm it's almost like this atomic little
slice of rock well that's what it's like
for a boy I felt like the first time you
get near that crotch area on a female
you know the first time you get your
hand up near that little female water
spout you know you just you know that
flat water spout really I should say it
just you're fired up I mean because
that's just I mean it's really it's the
first time I mean you came out of a
vagina as a child and then as a teenager
or whenever you get to touch some crotch
it's the first time you get back there
so you've really just been wandering
around for a long time away from your
you know your shuttle bus you know the
shuttle bus that brought you into
existence the female crotch and this is
almost oddly kind of fitting for
Mother's Day because we all came out of
a mother you know most of us anyway
unless somebody made you somewhere but
let's get to the call right now we got
Robin in Atlanta calling us and you are
on the line
Robin whoo I'm nervous Theo von my name
is Robin I'm from Atlanta you got a nice
voice you like that
these have these phone sex
they might have them we could call up at
night and spend a bunch of your parents
money and I listen to people talk about
dirtiness on the air and she have a nice
voice like those ladies or it's her own
word and I want to comment on about
everything that you say but I wanted to
comment specifically about the crotch
touching my first experience with having
my crotch touched was is this not
exciting everybody all of a sudden I'm
just like wow this is exciting day
because I want to know what girls
thinking onward touched was in the sixth
grade ooh naughty Robin young
okay sorry for interrupting a bunch
let's go on in the sixth grade in my
parents backyard in a refrigerator box
with my boyfriend Wow refrigerator box
well this is already awesome let me just
say that's already awesome I will never
and next time I see some kids making a
space shuttle out of one of those boxes
I'll never you know I will never second
guess that maybe they're up to more than
that that's for sure onward and I wasn't
concerned about it being that or nasty
it seemed pretty natural but I was
concerned because I knew these hands
were dirty and that they might be salty
and that salty hands yeah I mean that's
a concern I mean I mean it is a concern
it's your concern and I appreciate you
sharing it with us I mean this is an
intimate story but yeah I guess you
could worry if they got salt something
gets up there you know you don't want a
bunch of you know you want you don't
want things to start to pearl and Saudi
of a Jun and I don't look that can occur
or not but yeah I guess if you get a
little bit of salt in there could start
to pearl up over by the time your about
you know I mean I've probably got 12th
grade I think it takes about six years
for something new to Perl eyes anyway
onward they concern me a little bit but
it didn't it didn't end up stinging or
anything it did
make me feel funny for about a week you
know just some funny mentally I felt
like I had cross I'm threshold and
there's a question for you what's the
definition of fingering huh Wow
so I well first of all I made her feel
funny for like a week she said that's
interesting I do remember feeling like I
crossed some sort of threshold because
you don't have all you have is a million
mental images and ideas and gifts I
guess it or gif those little like video
images that they have now but back in
the time we just call them memories it
was like our ideas it was like a quick
idea you had in your head of something
and those are kind of like the gifts
that we have now I feel like you know um
but you'd have like this quick idea of
maybe what a crotch was like or what you
know but the fact that it was salty and
that and then and but then what you
found out once you found out what a
crocs was like I lost my train of
thought once you found out what a cross
was like you yeah you knew you had this
knowledge then you had this you know
you'd opened up this universe you know
it's like you've gotten like a special
warp zone or a special sword on Zelda or
something anyway let's go back to our
Robbins Cole thank you for the call
Robin fingering is fingering when you
put your finger in the vagina is that
technically the definition is that also
third base or is fingering just touching
and feeling around on the vagina oh you
know I thing is I think fingering is the
yes you got to go fingers in you know
you got to be checking levels there you
got to be Mark Twain and for anybody
that knows anything about see depth or
River depth you got to be you know you
got to be really uh digit and getting a
little bit of a stenographers practice
if you will yeah I think it's got to be
fingers
in and does it have to be one finger two
fingers I guess it just has to be one
you know two fingers is always crazy too
like I remember there were times you
know personally I put two fingers in a
woman's vagina and be like is this okay
or am I being crazy like I'm a crazy guy
you know and but I do remember Robyn
that that was a thing for guys it was
like how many fingers bro it was like if
you touch it wasn't enough in that you
would touch the vagina that you would
put a finger in to a local vagina it was
that you then had to do more fingers it
was what about all she could take 350
like it became this weird you know other
thing this bigger thing then it was just
it's like everything it's like once it
happens something happens more has to
happen you know you get you need a
bigger fix but I feel like yeah that's
third base was fingering and then as you
grow more adult you realize that there's
more action else there's there's more
action for the female outside of the
vagina you know inside you're basically
looking for something that's outside you
know it's like whenever you are you
bring your keys out to the car and you
leave and you have them in there but you
don't realize you have them in there and
you think you left them inside then you
go back inside looking for your keys
it's just like that it's like you go
back and it's like you keep your inside
a woman feeling around trying to get her
that pleasure but really the pleasure is
already outside you pass the pleasure
you had the pleasure you just didn't
realize you had it
so they'd see there a great analogy or a
horrible analogy I can't even tell it's
1:30 in the morning but let's listen to
the restaurants question or call it does
that consider Thursday's what's your
opinion about it
love your show I don't think you need
any gifts I can I really like to listen
to you ramble on whatever state you're
in you are a great loss of her and you
know dude sometimes really funny people
are just dark I'm sure doesn't mean
black she could be a Mike Epps fan I am
um I kept saying
I will say that I appreciate the nice
words Robin you know I don't know I mean
I appreciate you saying I'm really funny
I appreciate all the nice things you
said I appreciate your call it's cool
call very real you know you shared some
real thoughts there the I don't know
comedians are just dark people ask me
that a lot are you just dark I don't
know I don't know if comedians are that
way but I do know that there that I have
some type of affliction in me where I
get depressed you know and I battle it
much better these days you know like
this week I did make some choices I went
out I didn't want to go to yoga and I
went and I didn't want to go to the gym
and I went and and it made me feel
better whereas there were times before
like I'm just gonna lay down I'm just
gonna rest I'm just gonna sleep it off
and maybe I would take some naps but I
would just set my alarm and and I'd get
back up and I made some better choices
it was hard it was hard there were times
where I did not want to make that choice
but yeah I think back to your question
Robin or back to your in Korea its third
base that's touching crotch but the
weird thing is for guys it's just the
third base only goes one way it's not
like it doesn't matter what the girl
does to you
you know the throw base just only goes
one way and I remember and I'll tell you
the first time I you know the first time
that I touched a girl a gals crotch I my
buddy and I had a sleepover over here
out and um I didn't uh northa like
Franklinton Louisiana I mean small town
I don't even know where it was but it's
really just a bunch of people that are
lost and there's so many of them that
they called it a town like it's that
rural and we were out there on a double
date and some gal had a trailer out
there and her mother stepmother under
she had a mother or father but you might
ask that mother was out of town somebody
was out of town and we were over there
and and everybody was touching crops you
know and uh and the girl I was with
though was doing uh she had a minstrel
activities going on so I couldn't be a
part of it I could just be the outside
just around early
eggs and crotches touching that heat but
even that was huge just even feeling on
that area of a body and realizing that
there was no [ __ ] right there you know
because I was just used to my own area
or if I put my hands between my legs
[ __ ]
I find [ __ ] right there but if it's a
girl no [ __ ] and that alone was a big
enough change I mean I was just he
wrecked as a damn I mean just as a bird
beak I was hard as a damn cement bird
beak and and that was exciting I
remember that and then I remember we
went to a dance I think I've told this
story before and this is a little it's a
little profane but I'm gonna be real
Robin called in and she was real and
we'd had a school dance and a buddy
amounted touch some crotch he'd finally
you know gotten a third base you know he
was damn Ricky Henderson that night and
he slid in the third base and the gal
left and we were all fired up you know
and because one of us had finally gotten
you know he was damn Neil Armstrong to
us one of us had finally gotten to the
moon
you know and so he's got us you know
he's out there he's got his fingers out
and uh and my buddy's dad came out were
sitting around the fire and and me being
an instigator I told my buddies dad what
had happened you know I just wanted
everybody to be a part of what was going
on and my buddies dad started smelling
my buddies fingers we're in 7th or 8th
grade no older and my buddy's dad just
started smelling my buddy's fingers over
and over again and that was pretty
baffling and and he really kind of
smelled them all up like I remember at a
certain point later we tried to smell
him and there was no smell left on them
and I know that's dirty and I know
that's profane but we are you know we're
animals in a lot of ways we are fancy
fancy animals and I don't really believe
that I don't think but I do believe that
you know we have some of the same
likenesses as animals and so that's why
we wanted to smell you know just one of
the things you want to get that scent
you want to know what's going on you're
so curious
you know you're so curious but then
later I remember sleeping in my buddy's
house and I looked out the window and
his dad was out there still by that fire
and his dad was masturbating out into
that fire so that was pretty that was
pretty pretty intense but onward let's
take another call here and we got
another call this man calling in with
some crotch from Texas
hey Bo it's Michael from Patterson
California if you don't know where that
is it's uh it's centrally located okay
not Texas on word in the state but
anyway it's calling in to tell you about
my first time I touched a lady part I
was 18 I guess that's a late bloomer you
could say but uh I don't know if it's a
late bloomer I don't know if it's a late
bloomer you know it isn't it's when you
bloom brother you know I'm still late
blooming on stuff I can barely use a
calculator so onward anyway was this
girl I knew from high school she was a
year younger than me and we went to a
party one night not together she was
there and well dude I miss high school
parties dude dude if I could go back to
high school now and obviously not be an
adult cuz I don't to be some kind of
pedophile
but be like a high school kid it was so
easy to hook up with chicks
you just had no idea that was a problem
you had no idea you just couldn't see
that the look in most girl's eyes were
that they were curious we were just so
scared as well as young boys I felt like
anyway onward long story short I left
the party a little early
well after dropping my buddy off I was
on my way back to my parents house
almost there and I get a text message
and she says why'd you leave so early I
was looking forward to hanging out with
you well I don't really remember this
was over 10 years ago so I don't really
remember what we said but uh she said
she wanted you to come back to the party
okay onward
parked out by the road this was out in
the country Alma Alma boonies and she
met me out by the road and well one
thing led to another I popped down the
tailgate to my 94 Chevy Silverado ah god
this is beautiful dude
onward put her on the back and started
making out and uh I went for it I can't
get too fired up because there chill
there are only 18 you know I guess
they're legal I can listen going without
getting too graphic I mean I I'm letting
her pant zip and down didn't take her
pants all the way off yeah you'll take
her pants all the way off if you're
gonna finger a bro because that's creepy
as [ __ ] dude
okay if you're the kind that's like a
dude who pulls his pants all the way
down in the bathroom to urinate you ever
seen that boy when you were growing up
they had some always some creepy [ __ ]
pale ass kid or some big black kid would
have their pants all the way down to
their to their feet and their just pee
and what the [ __ ] anyway let's hear more
but I put my hand down there and flip
the finger in her and the first thing
slip the finger in ah yeah whoo whoa
whoo
onward so the first time slipping a
finger in a girl first thing I thought
was god damn this is the wettest thing I
wasn't expecting it to be so wet I mean
it was like a slip and slide I couldn't
believe how what it was I mean I was the
only thing that was going through my
mind the whole time damn bro way I'm
just wide you grew up in a G must have
grown up in a really dry County then um
anyway onward do that humidity bruh but
um but anyway so I'm gonna say what I do
it was damp bro I remember being like
whoa whoa this thing has had his thirst
quenched I do remember that is being
shocked like what is going on they're
hiding water around here you know
yeah I do remember that dinner I do
remember that you still catch it
occasionally with some older gals but
some of now it's like some of its like
kind of shuffling a little bit of a deck
of cards there on the outside and get a
little uh and get a little what I'm
gonna say you can get get a little
velvety on the outside anyway onward I
mean do you the first time you did it
were you surprised about how wet it was
I mean it was unbelievable it was
unbelievable
but I am unbelievable you know what I
think I was man I think I was you know I
think I was just i remembered as being
so erect I thought I was gonna faint
like so much because I was like a wide
penis and so much blood ran to my penis
that I just always get a little bit
faint whenever I get really erect so
that's like an issue that I've had kind
of like one of those universities go to
get that faint when they get scared kind
of like that my I feel like I'm kind of
like that sometimes with sex
onward anyway that they ended up leading
on my first [ __ ] same gal but that's
a different story for another time but
uh but anyway and one last thing
one thing I didn't like heading back
home was you know they you know some
people call it stinkfinger what my
fingers didn't really smell and I was
kind of bummed out I was the only thing
I was bummed out about they didn't smell
and could be honest I i wanted to smell
my fingers and go home and jerk off but
uh
Ambro you know what I gotta say this man
thank you for calling
you know because you know we people
could say oh that's gross that's nasty
you could say anything you want about
this fellow's call right here but the
truth is is that this is what a lot of
guys thought there's a thought that a
lot of guys have and Robins call us the
it was unique because it was something
that girls have it's there it's that but
that's out of the story from them you
don't yeah I don't
that's out of the saddle no fascinated
fascinated by both of these calls
fascinate about a nostalgia of this
second call and let me get his name
again right here so don't forget a Theo
it's Michael from Patterson California
Michael yeah Michael uh just fascinating
because yeah you I mean you got a I
think that's called like a golden
warlord or something if you don't get a
scent on your finger from a woman or a
woman that doesn't have a scent in her
crotch it's called like a golden warlord
or like a I don't know what it's called
just like a damn I mean it's definitely
that's more bottled water than sometimes
you get the gals a little tap you know
you get more tap water out of them but
that's beautiful man you know it's a
beautiful story and it just I mean I
just love the fact that you pulled her
pants down there that's [ __ ] what
crazy bro love it Michael
you're my hero this week dude you just
reminded me of what you know of a time
in in my life you know of being just
around that cooter and just being
unaware of what of another person's
crotch was like you know and just having
just uncertainty and just that magic
that was out in the universe and that's
one thing that happens as we get older
like we forget that we get used to
things
you know it's crazy when you think about
how insane you were about touching a
crotch of somebody else and then how now
that's not really I mean it's still an
issue but it's not as much it used to be
baffling baffling them on a difference
thank you so much for that Cole managed
to take me down memory lane I can't
remember you had a question for me I
don't even if felt was in there I'll
listen back later if so and get back to
you but just fascinating man just
fascinating to go back to those days and
just that heat it was like just that
body heat coming off just that area of a
woman was just fascinating and I
remember one time getting down there I
couldn't tell what was going on I
thought oh this one girl did even have
over
I thought you just had a bunch of crazy
you know skin activity god I remember
that just like what what is going on
where is this very scary and very
exciting very fun being young man let's
take one more call man we're going to
switch gears here and this one uh
this one is from Walnut Creek California
let's go and man actually I know like I
have some other calls I want to get some
more but I'll try to do some this week I
had a call coming in about sobriety that
I do want to answer but this is already
going to be a long episode and so I just
want to take a moment just to say thank
you guys so much for being a part of the
show for calling in
we'll feel whatever calls this week I
might put in as a Thursday episode some
ideas for you know for coming up for
other calls we can get I already have
people have left some voicemails about
the future and questions and eventually
will get it to call in where people can
call in and we can talk live even though
I don't even know if I could have dealt
live today with these calls today about
the crotches very fascinating man very
fascinating and I just want to thank you
guys so much man I love you and I
appreciate you and and yeah and I just
then I got some really nice calls and
voicemails and I really really
appreciate it and I'm gonna get to some
of these questions you know this one
cake called about some sobriety stuff
and I really want to get to it and I
will I will get to it's a hold on buddy
you know I promise that I'll get to it
and get it out this week because I want
to share with you whatever I can you
know [ __ ] do I need to get to it right
now let me get to it right now because
I'm gonna feel bad if I don't if I let
this go let's get it this is uh this
call it's changing the skirt you know
we've had I get you know it's been
whatever let's get to it here we go this
from a walnut
Creek California hey what's up there my
name's my name's miles and I was just
kind of wondering on like how you stay
sober
cuz I've been uh I've been taken you
know some pills here and there and it's
really fun but you know it's uh I feel
like it's just sort of time to time to
quit so I was just sort of wondering
like advice on on how to kind of deal I
guess with you know being sober because
you know to be honest it's really boring
like I don't like God spending whole
days you know the day seems like two
days and one now now that I've been
sober for for a week and I was just
wondering that's funny man uh he said
being sober is boring at Alette I mean
it's sad it's sad and perfect and
everything because it is it is kind of
boring man it's boring until you're able
to start dealing with some of your
feelings and what's going on and
whatever made you start to you know over
treat yourself with medication then it
gets interesting dude it gets
interesting man when feelings start
coming back and you start you start
having feelings man you know like what
I'm talking about my mom earlier and I
get like teared up you know like that's
that didn't used to happen to me man you
know like I wasn't able to access those
feelings dude when I you know when I see
like you know one of my friends posted a
picture of her and her baby his new baby
and I remember like a couple years ago
like telling her like almost was going
to like we're almost deciding that we
were gonna have a baby together even
though like we weren't in love or
anything we just were maybe going to
have a baby just because she's getting a
little older and we've always been
friends we both wanted just she I
thought she'd make a great mother
because she's always done like a great
friend
and she has a baby now dude I looked at
his saw head Trevor you know her first
Mother's Day or something today she
teared me up dude so you'll have real
feelings man and that's one thing that
can be exciting bro I know it sounds
crazy and probably gay as you know but
it's it's exciting bro but what was your
question how do I stay sober just
wondering like you know I guess how you
deal with it and I don't know if you've
ever you know taking pills or anything
like that but uh you know yeah I was
just wondering your dress I like to show
and uh actually just got your album so
keep it up man well man thank you for
the support let me catch your name again
I'm sorry hey what's up there my name's
lenin's Myles Myles thanks to the
support Myles I do appreciate it how do
I stay sober dude well I just decided
that I'm not gonna drink or use you know
and I didn't decide that I'm gonna do it
for the rest of my life because that's a
huge undertaking and I can't do anything
for the rest of my life
I can't perf I don't know what the rest
of my life is gonna be but I know that I
cannot drink or use for today you know I
know that and it look a lot of you guys
out there label dude I drink I use
that's fine I look I have no issue if
you can drink and you can party you can
have a good time and you can live your
life in your life's fun and comfortable
that's great you know I might be able to
do that one day I don't know but I do
know that for right now I'm not in that
position so how do I say sober man I
listen to people that are more sober
than I am and I I I try and figure out
what my feelings are you know because I
don't want to have any feelings I'm sure
that's why you take pills do pills bro I
remember one time I took a pill next
thing I knew it was Thursday bro and I
think when I started it was Friday so it
was like a long pill dude
yeah armor one time some new gave me
some sohmas this fellow too was
homosexual and he ended up dying he
drove a
I think Chevy Cavalier into an MC man
embankment and he was a boxer as a
homosexual prizefighter but he might
have even tried to blow me one time when
I was on so mazzani remember so our
pills fun I don't know I mean it was
definitely fun not having any feelings
and like just spinning up on my shirt
all night it was kind of cool it's like
being in the hospital but I was just in
the back of a Chevrolet Blazer but
overall long-term is it fun you know I
just don't think it's good because I
just would love for you to take a chance
and see what you're really like if you
don't use if you don't use pills you
know just take a chance look dude if you
don't like who you are where you don't
use pills go back go back to them bro
but at least give yourself a shot to see
who you are you're out here you know if
you got issues man look clean them up
you'll be able to clean them up when
you're sober I promise you it's gonna
take some time can be a pain in the ass
you have to sit and think and write and
listen other people probably have to cry
and listen to some [ __ ] dudes talk in
group settings and stuff where you're
like dude shut the [ __ ] up but you'll
get better it gets better I promise you
that and it's fascinating and it's the
ballsiest thing you could do you want to
take a pill take a pill oh [ __ ]
sobriety bro take a pill of you know
what whatever life throws at me today
I'm gonna look it in the [ __ ] face
you know take that pill that's a pill
bro you want a pill you want a ride you
want to ride try feeling everything so I
having conversations with people when
shit's uncomfortable and you can't
resort to anything else and you have to
you have to just tell them how you
really feel try that that's a pill bro
that's a pill man but I'm here for you
miles if you need me you can leave
another voicemail a private went on the
air that I won't use on on the episode
and but I don't know how I stay sober
man you know I invite a higher power in
my life even though I struggle with that
every day and I don't try to stay sober
forever I'm just trying to stay sober
for tomorrow you know but it's amazing I
started this podcast in sobriety dude if
I was still partying I wouldn't do that
I don't think I would have been able to
do it I don't know I don't think so
and I also don't wanna pigeonhole myself
and I don't want to tell you that you
need it forever I don't want to tell you
any of those things I don't want to tell
you that a a is a be all cure all end
all because if I don't if I don't I'm
not sober forever then people are gonna
be like well you did it you know it
didn't work for him I want to tell you
any of that man I just want to tell you
that I think it's worth to try you know
and I think it's worth the same amount
of effort you go you put in to getting
pills or using pills just at least give
it that same amount of effort see how it
works you know it might work well but um
but I love you miles man and uh and you
know it sounds like you want to at least
try to get I don't know better but you
want to try to get different so just try
to get different man see how different
works thank you for calling but I really
do appreciate it
and happy Mother's Day to all the
mothers man I'm going to take us out of
here man it's getting late god it's
silly this is going to be up late guys
it's going to be up late because it's
already 2:00 a.m. here it's 5:00 a.m.
East Coast it's not going to be there
for people on the drive to work so I'm
sorry about that
it's just it's going to take a couple
hours to edit all right man but I'm
going to take you out here man it's been
a beautiful law it's been a beautiful
time chat and I hope so thank you to our
callers hit the hotline you know what it
is check out my tour dates at the ov on
Comm slash tour and just tell somebody
you loving today call your mother again
today and tell you you love her how
about that huh
I was just calling your mother again
today and just letting her know you love
her
just let her you know hey mom you know I
love you just as much today I just want
to let you know that you know I know I
know mother's day was yesterday bye
[Music]
but there's gonna come a day when I
might not be able to tell you how much I
love you so today's not that day and
today I'm gonna let you know how much I
care you know
man we get so caught up dude hey and we
get so caught up talking to other people
you know it's hard it's harder for us to
listen to our mothers but I don't know
man I don't know and maybe some of you
guys are the best relationship with your
mother and I'm not trying to make you
feel bad or you know but I don't either
you know it sometimes it's horrible my
mother says stuff I don't feel it but
we're to keep trying man you know we
keep trying that's all we can do just
keep trying man and love yourself today
you know if you don't have a mother bra
put on a wig and I'll hug you dude how
about that dude we just got to keep it
all about you know first base only and
that's only on the cheek you know that's
my motherhood for you but thank you guys
for for listening to this past week and
I'll see you guys next time
be good to yourselves man he probably
deserved
[Music]